i feel like right now we're kind of
you know chicago's had so many waves of
of uh
success from the 90s till now obviously
twisted calm and kanye you know all that
then chance and
and vic mensa and chief keef and all
that was kind of going on around the
same time and you you were part of
a lot of the drill scene but i feel like
right now
between you dirk polo g like it feels
like
this has been the biggest that
chicago hip-hop has ever been like it
feels like it's crazy
it's a crazy thing to say no no no
obviously kanye
i'm not trying to take away from kanye
as being the biggest artist in the world
but i just mean when you look at the
landscape of who's the hottest
[ __ ] in hip-hop
right like it's a lot of chicago and
it's never really been like that it's
always been like one guy
but it's like y'all really running [ __ ]
up right now in a way that's like not
fair to a lot of other regions
and what's dope is you and dirk just
your
evolution since you started it's been so
special to see
because you guys have grown as musicians
grown as rappers grown as
men you know what i'm saying and
the longevity there's something to be
said about that as well man no i've been
hearing that a lot though i'm not even
gonna lie like you're not even the first
person to say that you know
just from the outside looking in maybe
it looked a little different yeah
i don't know i like what everybody doing
you know what i'm saying but it's just
something different about chicago but we
grind differently
you know you know it's not no quitting
us like and i always say that i'll be
telling people like
man you can't really like take none of
this [ __ ] personal in the industry when
you go through [ __ ] all the adversity
that come with you well we didn't
mention juice world too yeah of course
r.i.p brother man you know that's that's
that's a given like automatically you
know but
chicago just i feel like we built for
pressure
we built for pressure we don't really
you know burst under pressure
and those people who last the longest
especially in this industry because it's
going
you're going to be under pressure you
know what i'm saying so i think that's
what stand out the most to me about you
know
being from chicago and seeing other
chicago artists like succeed and [ __ ]
how's um you know obviously appear yours
dirk is is
having the best year of his life but
he's also faced a lot of personal losses
recently
um have you been in contact with him
recently oh yeah you know i'll reach out
to bro on a regular basis so you know
what i'm saying is
especially um you know recently after
after the you know the untimely past
nights brothers
i reached out yeah yeah you know we
locked in how big of a loss do you think
just
you know two opposite sides of the
spectrum but losing juice world and then
losing
king vaughn within inside of 12 months
for the city man it's crazy no it's
different bro like we take a lot of
losses in chicago man i don't know
it's like maybe it's a dark cloud over
that [ __ ] or something that's why i
don't really
i i don't know like you you can't take
it personal though like
it's like i don't know something about
this shot i feel like when you do that
you fall under it you know what i'm
saying you gotta like just
try to keep pushing you know like i
don't know it's i'm not gonna say it's a
bad thing
like going on in chicago i never really
i can't really speak bad about chicago
of course as much as
i mean it's home man yeah